We're going to focus in on this idea of opposite polynomials. For two polynomial
expressions to be opposite, every corresponding pair of terms must opposite in
sign. We know addition is commutative so we can rewrite these terms by adding
the opposite. I'll move the negative x squared to the front, the 3x to the
middle, and the negative 8 to the end. Notice that when we move these terms
around, we just keep the sign with it. The three x's are positive, the eight is
still negative and the x squared is also still negative. Now we can definitely
see that these two polynomials are opposites. The x squared terms are opposites
since one is positive and the other is negative. The three x's are opposites
since one is negative and the other is positive And the eights are opposites,
since the first one's positive and the second one's negative. And the neat part
about opposite polynomials and rational expressions is that they simplify to
negative1 . We can think about factoring a negative 1 from each of these terms.
So we'll have negative 1. Times the opposite sign of all those terms in the
denominator. The numerator will just stay the same and we can think about
multiplying it by a positive 1. Here we have a common factor in the numerator
and a denominator, so this all equals 1. And finally, since we have this
negative sign down in the denominator, our answer simplifies to negative 1.